lucky luke revient au cinéma avec tous à
l'ouest le sympathique cow-boy qui tire
plus vite que son ombre a mobilisé
l'énergie de plus de 200 personnes dans
un studio parisien dominique poncet
lawrence où je vous renvoie frein mais
obtenir au plein
c'est lui qu un culot monstre une
imagination débordante
une patience d'ange et un savoir faire
hors faire lui qui mixe jeudi j'abuse ce
cow-boy quelque part vous fait l'homme
qui tire plus vite que son ombre
il fallait la réunion de tous ces
éléments pour oser sortir lui qui dicte
son univers de papier glacé et l'emmener
vivre sur grand écran en voix et en
mouvement le projet a été porté par un
fan de bd c'est clint eastwood
moi j'étais le hocini fait partie d'une
génération à la maison avait astérix
lucky luke c'est avec cette bd qui
pouvaient y avait le droit de rentrer à
la maison
on va proposer faire le film master
abbaoui sahara est le plaisir quoi de
pouvoir le porter au grand écran
le scénario écrit un road movie vers
l'ouest raconter sur les chapeaux de
roue on a d'abord avant toute chose
enregistré les voix
les comédiens ont donc travaillé chez
eux avec le texte sans aucun support
images oui c'est très sympathique à
faire c'est bien parce qu'on peut
improviser on peut penser à des choses
faire des propositions différentes et
puis après
le réalisateur et les dessinateurs
l'easa ça m'amuse à faire j'aime de dieu
ne peut pas qu'on marche en cabine ils
se sont bien amusés les acteurs surtout
françois morel qui rentrent en planches
volent comme des bâches
les voix enregistrée la sphère ses
forces et les 230 technicien a subie aux
parisiens sont entrés en action pour
faire vivre 280 personnages et des
milliers des corps en deux et trois
dimensions
vingt mois de travail et 220 mille
dessins plus tard tous à l'ouest et est
enfin terminé le résultat de la rigolade
l'émotion de l'art au monde de la poésie
c'est pour un dépôt et aussi du rythme à
couper le souffle et encore du business
soit maintenant un déçu un bus relais
qui évoque celui de l'inénarrable buster
keaton bon